[音楽]
一応をそう月なんですけどが妄想家庭に東京くることなんてないんで大発見なんです
けどめっちゃ黒鳩人が少ないんでそうそう初の東京建物とかねと回かめっちゃ好きなん
で人のあの大阪府すごいやだけでこんだけ人少なかった杉江には東京が言いやすいです
はじめ
ぐっ
お肉1年間禁止
おつかれさまでした
よせよ収集し
あの1年間一切お肉
食べませんです俺のまわりにいる奴に行けばわかると思いますが本当に一切お肉食べ
ませんでした
2019年よお肉を食べる時がやってまいりました
あたすで行く1月1日なんですけどもお肉を食べるためだけに東京に行きました
俺はもう一でもがましたから誘導がならそこらへんのハンバーグ屋さんとかそういう
次元じゃなくてもう
総会はもっと高いおいしいにくくてーじゃねーかということで東京の方急激に木や山に
わざわざ来ましたいやーもう1月1日にやってる店が少ないですからね
レアですよねだけで今回は高級焼き肉店ということで高級焼き肉店にそう c
スペシャルゲストをお呼びしておりますその後と一緒に今日はミ肉を食べていきは者は
誰だと思いますか
他の動画もたブサ女になったような構図で到着するらしいですねあの趣味やなおまあを
ちょいでくると思うんですけどもお肉きじ亭方の僕の中で結構いろんな変化があったん
で思い当たる点だけ皆さんにお伝えしていこうと思います上までその1本当にきつい
ですできれば二度とやりたくないし
ガスト s がすごかったですみんな想像できるかいアンバーグの食べる眠いと椿
ても食べるビッグマックを食べるチーズ前が求められ地図を求めだよドームずれない
さあもほとんど食べれなサンドイッチも食べれないか入ってるから僕の好きなもの
ほとんど食べれない前だったからねほんとに引っかかったんですがあと食べることが
本当に少ないんですよ大抵のご飯で実はお肉が入っててびっくりしますよコンビニの原
材料綿とか見るとほとんどに帰って
ですからね非常に苦しい1年でした2つ目食べる物がなくて食料が固定されていけば僕
基本的にツナタマゴサンドがシーチキンのお寿司
この2つぐらいしか基本的に食べなくなりましたお肉ん時の野菜カレーとかなそん
ぐらいをずっとループしてましたねほんとに食べるレパートリーがめちゃくちゃ減り
ました
3つ目ベジタリアンの人があった
があるんですけどあのみんなすごい穏やかなんですよね優しいというかやっぱ肉食って
ないせいか何か心が絶甲穏やかになった気がしましたそうではないか欲しいんですけど
普段の自分よりかはなんかそんなカッカしたりイライラしたりすることがすごい減った
ような気がしましたただそれに伴ってや敵が出ないわけじゃないんですけども若干ね
パワーがなかったというか何かを
やりきろうっていうなんかこのガッツみたいなの出なかった多分肉がないからもい
なかったんだと思いますがなんと僕の個人的な感想ですよ何度やっぱ肉食わねえと
ガッツは出ないのは間違いないなと思います
去年1年間すごいねおいてあげる投資見たいのはなかったですすごいクールな一年だっ
たような気がしました
ぐらいかな肉食った方がいいの服はない方がいい
僕にはわからないですけど肉喰いてぇなって思いましたねはい
にくく以来ですやって食うために来たねちょっともうもう着いたみたいですと開いて
いきましょう
こんなどこにおるんやろうなをまあどこの利益なぁ mitre
も趣味やなぁ今正今日もガチャまわしてくれよまあ本文もいいと言うと緊張所やネオン
もうマイさあ
どっから空路なぁ舞さんでしょありがとうございますそれ
まあなったよ
と思っていますいやー上尾市めでとうございますがたくさん来ましたございますじゃあ
またが死んで一発目が日本中 youtube ですか
ほらっ覚醒じゃなくじゃないか枠でございます実は
photos 市竈ばいいんですよ夏だけで新年一発目は
ピカルさんとこう行く行きまーす
ブーバー毎年あっ大戦争でもう
ショーツワーカーさんヌーです
[音楽]
夏燃えてるの俺初めて行っそうですねあんな上げ学校奴ちょっと使い去ったわけや
4日
ああああああ
me
動いた
1 b ビザ配偶者又メリッ
おおっなんで伝わったの使うかホール出すです
体を割る機体ながら肉をはじめ所はちょっとだけをや管理やそうそういやほんとそう
ですよ
徐々に金本さんが僕のことないやり方じゃない
降りましょうからありがとうござ
ちょっと皆さんちょっ w ただ分野させ
家族で使った通りは4つで4つパッ抱卵食べてるからご飯
でしょ
越前食べたけど何がなんだかわからんこれまで本当に取れないですねますが満腹の牧場
だけをアジアにえはい
あず読んでです w
ブーブー所
これが一番おいしい zero 1000ブーブー女性
です私は壁ですやばいねそれは
いやば2
ほんまに名前をとっては今日からも肉がってため今日から肉しか食わんですよ
ちょっと enjoy ないてそういう感じです
youtube 会津大大大真実インター日本はレベルなんていうことでちょい
ネットで便利役だろうすごい怖いだというコンマイ
嘘難しいとかです
家へホンダ中で食べるんだすごい
いただきます f 早まらないでくださいね
せーの居酒屋 b 光さんにカメラを持っててるじゃない
今から始めしちゃうの
二階議員はずですよ本当に初音屋も最初は去ったさあ何も付けずに行ってもいいんじゃ
肉だけでイクッイッ
菅居さんはそうこのままいきます
すごいなぁ
これやってないでおいて鳥を撮ってるけど水武道に行くぜええ
[音楽]
どうぞこれで黄熱母はするんやっ
肉のアレよびっくりの姉がわかるんですよ
全部じゃないなぁって柔らかいん前は10枚いやーんんは今なぜだったんだろう
ございます
me
ああああああああ
木カメさんの金で君に食って仲間と言うねぇ
大変な金9分焼きにくらい経ったら年齢ブループロいら people are 者
梅原なぁ
うまいなんでまぁ
俺チームでないけど3月るんですが僕と裏や
お前はうーんまみんな
こう本当にないぞ
20台買おう
あっはっはー
ふーんエースを応援化すれば狙っ彦根よって体の待ってましたんだか
まあ見てないの上で起こっちゃうぞ
うーんまあなんか本番さん
水を追い求めて差額は11年しての企画はもうなんてと倍三倍と上げるためられました
逆にこそどうした
背景美味しいございますが玉出かけ結構いい
結構んっ
近年一発目から
弟妹使ってしまったカラーやラッキーマンいいね
50あっいやーもういつでもよってくださいもよくは行ったらしいぞ
などゆけあああ
[音楽]
me
car
あっはぁ
揺らしてほしいないですかああああああいう灯油
そう
店長 f 話ですコトノハ